THE REACTION BY STEWART ELEVATED
IT FOR LeBRON TO GET THE ONE
GAME SUSPENSION.
>> I AGREE WITH REGGIE.
LeBRON HAS BEEN IN THE LEAGUE
17, 18 YEARS.
HE HAS NEVER BEEN THAT GUY.
WHEN YOU ARE GOING STRENGTH
AGAINST STRENGTH.
YOU HAVE TO PUT THE EXTRA UMPH
IN TO IT, STEWART ACTED LIKE YOU
ARE SUPPOSED TO REACT.
>> THAT'S NOT HOW YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO REACT.
>> YEAH, YOU DO.
SOMEBODY HITS YOU IN THE FACE,
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO --
>> THAT WAS NOT AN OVER THE TOP
REACTION.
>> NO, NO, SOMEBODY HIT YOU IN
THE FACE, YOU HAVE TO HIT THEM
BACK OR ACT LIKE YOU WANT TO.
TWO OPTIONS.
>> LET'S --
>> NO, NO, IT WAS TWO OPTIONS.
>> IT WAS HILARIOUS IN THIS
REGARD.
ALL RIGHT, IF HE WOULD HAVE
REACTED LIKE THAT THE FIRST TIME
HE, LIKE WHEN HE GOT HIT, I
WOULD HAVE BEEN LIKE YEAH OUT
MAKES SENSE.
BUT THE WALK WITH THE LADIES AND
THEN FAKE LIKE YOU ARE GOING THE
OTHER WAY AND THEN -- THAT'S
WAY --
>> HE BLACKED OUT AT THAT POINT.
>> HE BLACKED OUT.
>> I KNOW ISAIAH.
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON, I'M UP
FROM SEATTLE.
AND I KNOW HE IS BIG ON -- HE
RESPECTS EVERYBODY.
BUT IF HE FEELS DISRESPECTED
THINGS GO TO ANOTHER LEVEL.
>> HE GOT HIT.
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN HIM LIKE
THAT.
THEY WERE JOSTLING --
>> I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT -- IF
IT WAS IMMEDIATE.
BUT THE SUSPENSION FOR HIM.
>> HE REACTED AFTER THE BLOOD
STARTED TO COME DOWN.
>> FIVE MINUTES LATER.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED, HE
GOT HIT AND PEOPLE CALMED HIM
DOWN, HE FELT DISRESPECTED AND
WALKED AROUND, ERNIE, I'M OKAY.
KENNY I'M OKAY, AND THEN --
THAT'S WHEN THE ANIMAL CAME OUT.
>> THAT'S THE OVER REACTION.
>> GO AHEAD, REGGIE.
GO AHEAD.
>> IT WAS THE BLOOD.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT TRIGGERED
HIM.
BECAUSE AND I AGREE WITH JAMAAL,
HE IS A GOOD KID.
HE IS A HARD WORKER.
HE RESPECTS THE GAME.
AND AFTER THE HIT, THE INITIAL
CRACK WHEN LeBRON WENT TO HIM.
I THINK LeBRON WENT TO HIM TO
MAKE SURE HE WAS ALL RIGHT.
HE WAS FINE THEN.
IT'S ONCE THE BLOOD, ONCE HE
TASTED THE BLOOD, THE DOG
STARTED TO COME OUT OF HIM.
>> REGGIE, YOU A